-Now, we all love our pets,
and every pet owner thinks
that their pet is the best.
Well, I wanted to see
if that was true,
so it's time for, "Why is Your
Pet Better Than Me?"
Here we go.
♪♪
-♪ Why is your
pet better than me? ♪
♪ Better than me ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Alright, let's meet
our first pet.
Hello there.
Hey, what's your name,
and where are you from?
-Hello. I'm Florian,
and I'm from Germany.
Morty, come.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Whoa!
Whoa! I love that already.
I love -- All the way
from Germany.
Thank you so much
for being on our show.
I love that.
Already, I can see why
your pet is better than me.
What is the name of your dog?
What kind of dog is that?
-He's a 5-year-old
Australian shepherd.
-I love those.
-And, yeah, he's pretty awesome.
-What -- Is that his talent?
What is his talent?
-His talent is, he got all
the trust in the world for me,
and he even does
a trust fall with me.
-Oh, my gosh.
Florian, what is
your dog's name again?
-Morty.
-Yeah, Morty.
Alright, can we see Morty --
Can we see Morty do
a trust fall with you?
This is hilarious.
-Sure.
-Oh, my gosh.
[ Drumroll ]
Wow!
Right there is amazing, huh?
Oh, my gosh. Be careful, Morty.
-Ready?
-Oh, my gosh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow!
Whew! Oh, my gosh!
Wow! Morty!
Great job, Morty.
You scored right there, buddy.
Thanks for coming on the show.
All the way from Germany.
That was great.
-Thank you.
-Let's meet our next pet
right here.
Oh, wow!
[ Laughs ]
Well, it must be
sunny where you are.
Hello. What is your name,
and where are you from?
-My name is Jess.
This is Cooper.
And we're from Mission Viejo,
California.
-Ah! Mission Viejo.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-I love Cooper's sunglasses.
Can you tell me,
why is Cooper better than me?
-Cooper can make
a really good silly face.
-Oh, really?
Oh, I'd love to see --
Now -- [ Laughs ]
He's really cute.
He can make a silly face.
Alright, Cooper, let's see this.
Roots, can we get
a drumroll, please?
[ Drumroll ]
-Okay, Cooper,
on the count of three,
do your best silly face, okay?
One, two, three.
-[ Laughs ]
♪♪
I love it.
No, no, that's awesome.
I love you and I love Cooper.
Thank you, Jess,
for bringing him on the show.
Hey, Cooper. Good doggy.
Good doggy. Hi, buddy.
Oh, yeah, good job.
Good job, buddy.
Let's meet our
next pet over here.
Hello. What is your name,
and where are you from?
-Hey. My name is Allison Flake,
and I'm from Houston, Texas.
-Ah, hey, welcome.
Thank you very much.
We love Houston.
Allison,
what is your pet's name?
-His name is Astro,
for the Houston Astros.
-There you go. Astro.
Now, what is Astro's talent?
-So, he can catch
foam golf balls.
-Alright, I got to see this
golf-ball action here.
I love golf.
Roots, can we get
a little music here?
♪♪
-Astro, you ready?
-Alright, bud.
-Come on.
-He's just kind of
sitting there.
[ Laughs ]
-Are you ready? Come on.
I like this. Watch this.
[ Laughs ]
I love this cat.
-More? Come on, come on.
-You ready, bud?
-Ready?
-Yes! 3 for 3!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Astro!
I love that. Good job, Astro.
Allison, thank you so much
for bringing him on.
I really appreciate it.
Good job.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's meet our last pet here.
Hello. What is your name,
and where are you from?
-Hello. My name is
Lindsey Wadden,
and we are from Maple Ridge
in Canada.
-Oh, hey!
Thank you so much, Lindsey.
Now, I think I have an idea
what's going to happen,
but who is there with you,
and what kind of dog is that?
-This is Ollie, and he is a
7-year-old border collie.
Say hi.
-Oh, my gosh.
Say hi. That's cute already.
Oh, my gosh.
Now, don't even tell me
the dog is going to play Jenga.
Is that true?
-Yeah, he's going to try.
-This is amazing.
I would love to see this happen.
And this just happens?
You have game night, and he just
comes over and starts playing?
-Yeah, we do.
-Yeah.
I love this. Alright.
-Ready?
-Roots, could we maybe
get a drumroll, maybe?
[ Drumroll ]
-Okay. Okay, wait.
Slow it down.
-Do you want to
stick that one -- Ooh!
-Gentle. Yep, that one.
Get it. Get it.
Good boy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes! Yes!
Yes! Good job!
Ollie, great job!
-Good job!
-Great job to all of
our talented pets.
If you think you have a pet
that is better than me,
I want to see it.
Go to tonightshow.com/
whyisyourpetbetterthanme,
submit a video of your pet.
Thank you very much.